hey guys I'm back last time I posted a
video I was in Romania there's a fly
that's like trapped in my hotel room
excuse me if I get distracted
anyway I last time I post a video I was
in Romania finishing up was very
disappointing tournament I was traveling
with a friend Costa Kavinsky
who tied for first in the turn in
Romania and now we're both here in
Inverness case pain basically in the
heart of the Pyrenees surrounded by
mountains pretty small town
I think there's it's like 2,000 people
that live in this town but there's 500
people who come for this chess
tournament so the town increases pretty
significantly in population and I played
this event last year which I mean it was
a really well run event really nice
environment so I'm back again
for this time around and I thought I
would just go ahead and show a game that
I played last year try and bring back
some some good memories show some
hopefully show some kind of inspiration
it was a game that I played in one of
the earlier rounds I was playing against
someone just rated over 2000 and I
managed to win in 18 moves now I don't
want to show the notations I think
there's a trick here I can just click
this and then it hides a notation but
the moves should still be there which is
good so yeah I'll take I'm going to go
through the game trying to make this
instructive and then probably towards
the end I'll share some announcements
and yada yada okay so I was playing
Sicilian and I remember preparing for
this opponent and only finding games
from like the 1990s and then the 1990s
he played a c4 on move - so that was the
only thing I prepared before
this game and that's what happened he
played c4 and the normal move here for
Black is knight c6 just to simply
control the d4 square in this game I
played Knight f6 it was part of some
some pregame preparation trying to
induce this move e5 now normally nine f6
is not the type of move you would play
as black just because II five looks
annoying however there is an interesting
line if I play z5 I would simply move
back to g8 and e pawn is a bit
overextended and I could try and
demonstrate this let's say Knight to f3
knight c6 Knight c3 there's a nice
positional idea here for black - it's
not really to try and win the e pawn but
it's simply to get a comfortable
position
it's just start with this move T six and
then after kwon-taek D six black can
play e5 and then that's really
comfortable for black its Bishop take T
six is coming black house in my center
good space so yeah I would be content
here and this is one of the main ideas I
was kind of familiar with before the
game but he didn't play d5 he played
Knight c3 and we develop lady six
actually show the game I think the last
video I uploaded I had shown my my last
round game from the turn in Romania and
I had like the the similar position but
reverse so I added extra tempo in the
same structure and usually with pawns on
like this on e4 and c4 one of the main
ideas is to play d5 try and break
everything apart and in this position I
think my opponent played a sub optimal
move I think that there's a few choices
for white here if I'm not mistaken this
is some sort of theory I think II five
is possible here Bishop e2 I think would
be my choice but my opponent played g3
is a bit slow because it requires extra
moves to develop the bishop and it gives
me time to to get initiative to try and
put the focus in the center so that's
what I do play d5 we trade and then he
plays Queen e2 which is probably just a
bad move because it's only helping me
like I want to develop my bishop and
castle and Queenie to really has no
benefit for white on so this was a big
problem for my opponent this game is the
facts that he was just really slow to
develop first with g3 men with Queen e2
and he's just making my life very easy
so he plays g3 here and now in the
situations like this when your opponents
slow to develop user you want to look
for ways to grab initiative as early as
possible so that's what I was looking
for in this position I found a nice nice
sequence starting with taking and Bishop
f5 and this looks like just a normal
developing move but it has a deadly
threat to it and if I'm not mistaken
there's only one playable move for white
in this position so I'll give you or is
a chance to pause the video to identify
the threat for black and identify what
white should do to stop the threat so
the the deadly threat is night before so
if white just tries to develop like
Bishop g2 the night before is just
deadly because might see 293 and Bishop
d3 these are all pretty much unstoppable
moves and White's gonna lose material in
one way or the other
like castling runs into Bishop d3 if the
King stays in the center and I see -
probably comes so white white has to
play a three here and that's what my
opponent did but then it just gives me
more time to develop so I are not not
necessarily develop I just continue
initiative so that's why I do 94 we
trade and then he plays Queen e5 which
kind of surprised me
uh attempting to complicate matters
counter attacking the bishop he allows
me to take the night I just played
Bishop e6 keep the attack against the
Knights also his queen is now a target
on e5 which can allow black further
initiative as we'll see I'm pretty sure
just in a few moves
he plays Knight d5 making some threats
of Knight c7 so I just Castle and then
he wins d4 so white is up a pawn here if
I can count but white is severely behind
in development and the fact that black
has castled and has all the minor pieces
developed it just it's a prime position
to to basically punish the opponent for
having most of the pieces still on on
the first rank and that's what I do and
I was very happy with my next move the
next move is somewhat multi-purpose move
it's a positional move it's a tactical
move it defends against White's threats
white wants to take the bishop so I
played Bishop g4 and the main threat
with this move is is nice Bishop before
check and rook e8 just targeting the
fact that the Queen and King are aligned
on the open file so white has to defend
you play Bishop e3 which is a decent try
I think it was around here it was either
like right before I played Bishop g4 or
when he played Bishop e3 was a moment
when I saw the the finish to the game I
saw the the potential way this game
could finish in a very beautiful manner
and it's it's already like just winning
for black but the way in which black
wins is pretty nice I start with a
natural move rook e8 my opponent plays
Queen b5 and now it's black to move
and okay there might be a few strong
continuations here but this is black to
move and play the strongest and most
beautiful a combination or most
beautiful move feel free to pause the
video I'm thinking what I'm going to
name the title of the video is just
gonna give the the move away but but
whatever people will have some kind of
clue the move here is Queen take T for a
queen sacrifice an amazing thing is that
white can't while if white does take it
it's checkmates bishop before just such
a beautiful Nate's King in the center
but this is a power of in this case this
is double check needs we see double
check on occasion but we rarely see
double check mates we're yeah black
black has a rook and the bishop
attacking the king and whenever it's
like a double check situation the no
piece can be captured and a double check
can't be blocked the King would have to
move but in this case the King just has
no squares due to the bishops
so I was really happy to get this over
the board
my opponent played this move Queen
taking eights doesn't really change
anything
rook takes Bishop take d4 and Bishop b4
mates so this was just a feel-good game
trying to bring back some some kind of
memories before I I play the second year
in a row of this tournament tomorrow by
thought this is a nice example goes to
show why development is important and
what sort of terrible things can happen
to someone who doesn't develop quickly
enough and as in this case it was white
getting punished very often we can see
black getting punished
from early on given that black has as a
second move but yeah stuff like this
happens so it's important to to be aware
and sometimes just pay attention to this
simple opening print
fools of developments in king safety so
I won't say too much more about this
game I'm hoping to I'm hoping to do more
content throughout this tournaments I do
want to make a note that for every game
that I play for the next 10 days I'll be
doing analysis recaps on coasts yaku
boots Keys channel which I'll link in
the description for the last tournament
we did it on my channel now we'll do it
on his channel but I'm still gonna try
and do some like extra videos maybe
behind the scenes may be more like
lifestyle videos this is a really cool
environment for a chess tournament I
have an amazing view out the window I
wonder if I could show the view can I
show the view can people couldn't make
the webcam bigger people can kind of see
that this is my view if people want to
follow me on instagram i'll be posting
like mountain pictures and whatnot but
tonight is a very very big like
lightning storm not the most ideal
outdoors weather anyway
yeah I think I'm gonna end it there it's
11:40 p.m.
rounds are every day at at 4 p.m. so I'm
pretty sure I don't know how I'm gonna
upload this to YouTube actually because
when I upload this it might be tomorrow
because of Wi-Fi is bad that's one of
the reasons I'm not streaming this week
is just the Wi-Fi is almost unbearable I
am using my my hotspot for Lee chess
when I need to just because I need Wi-Fi
on occasion but I do have a limited
amount of data
so anyway I'm not gonna make this any
longer
hope you guys enjoyed that and I will
see you sometime in the near future
bye